listen i got a few minutes with you
today
and i always debate what i'm going to
ask you about because there's
a million things i want to talk to you
about but for today
uh i love the movie the game which is
david fincher is the game
uh and i wanted to know if you could
share a little bit about what it was
like working on that
and did you get along with fincher's
method of doing a lot of takes or was it
something that was difficult for you
it was difficult for me um i mean i
i love david the experience was great
but he
he pushes you to the limit i mean he
just you know
because he sees stuff that you don't see
that makes him want to try it
uh again but you knew
i knew i was in very good company and
quality so you try
you try to do it do the best you can
but it is exhausting it is exhausted and
i've never worked with anybody
quite like that who did who does as many
takes
you've produced so many different
projects and i'm curious
throughout your career was there ever
anything that you really tried to get
made
that you couldn't for whatever reason
and it's like
you know one of those things that still
like sort of haunts you like i wish i
could have made that
yeah i i had the option on on tom wolf's
novel a man in full
which was a a great a great story takes
place in atlanta georgia
uh most of it and i just could not get
that across
the line and i i find myself thinking
about that over the years i'm still
haunted by it
i think it's still timely may still try
to get it going
my last thing for you before we get into
kaminsky which is fantastic
uh you directed an episode of the
streets of san francisco in the 70s
and i believe that was your only time
that you directed something
was directing something that you ever
thought about doing after that or was it
like okay this is too much for me i
don't want to do that
no no i i really wanted to direct but
because i had the success as a producer
uh after cuckoo's desk came out early in
my career
and i was able to have a big producing
career most of the time with me having
the final cut
in terms of contractually so i never
felt
uh i never felt deprived like a lot of
actors might feel and the producing
always allowed me
and i was usually very much in stick
with the directors a lot of times even
if the director didn't have a final cut
i used to give my my cut because there
was never
uh really an argument and then you
reached a point where i'm saying i want
to go direct
uh but in the venomous report we start
getting a little too old and too lazy
but i still may pull it off got it okay
jumping into why i get to talk to you
today
fantastic final season uh and like i
said to you for season two
i think that while all the performances
on this series are so good
it's really chuck's writing that
elevates this to another level and he's
done it again in season three
can you sort of talk about working with
chuck and his fantastic
scripts well thank you for saying
something i i
i don't have to because that's that's my
biggest my biggest note you know i mean
the writing is the foundation whether
it's television or movies that is the
foundation everything is built upon
and from the very first episode that
chuck sent me to
when he offered me this uh this show i
was just blown away about how good the
writing
the writing was and i think it just
elevates
everybody then you combine that with
chuck's uh
great production department he has he
has casting he's casting people have
been with him for like 20 years
he casts impeccably uh in all of them
and he he has a tendency to find people
that are good too
pleasant to work with no you know
no i don't know [ __ ] around here i
mean you just
all really good people so you can find
talented people that are good
so yes i think that makes the difference
then they get someone like paul reiser
uh is as good a comedian as you as
you're gonna find
i can't say enough about about chuck uh
and in the level and when we started
this third season and he was telling me
yeah we're gonna start with alan arkin
and the funeral his funeral
i said chuck chuck we can't start the
comedy
with alan's yeah weekend and
i i saw it the other day i just saw that
i just saw all the episodes for the
first time the other day it was it was
just brilliant such a great job
having these people come up and really
laying out allen's character
and he's pretty prevalent for the whole
third season between what he gives us in
the will
my acting opportunities you know so well
done chuck
well done yeah 100
what is it like though what's
interesting about this is you're playing
an acting coach while you are an amazing
actor
and i'm just curious what is chuck
writing what you're actually gonna say
when you're standing on stage
and how much is it sort of like you
giving feedback like because you're
it's a really good performance and
talking about you know uh you're talking
about how to mourn someone or how to
play a death scene
and there's a lot of layers if you will
i i give all the credit to chuck know i
i he had no
no feedback from me as far as dialogue
uh
or or tone rather was me
really trying to learn to just
these these beautiful presentations and
speeches and trying to find the correct
the correct rhythm and all of that i'll
be eternally grateful to him he made
this a
wonderful wonderful experience i have to
go
i will just say i'm looking forward to
the next ant-man movie and um
thank you so much for answering my
questions and have a fantastic day
good to see you again my pleasure